thank you very much for joining us the
tops Democrat in the US Congress Nancy
Pelosi says President Donald Trump must
be impeached and removed from office her
statement comes as the impeachment
process enters its latest phase the
House Judiciary Committee is deciding on
charges for the House of Representatives
to vote on the final report from the
intelligence committees inquiry said
Trump abused his power to pressure
Ukraine into investigating his political
rival Joe Biden our democracy is what is
at stake the president leaves us no
choice but to act because he is trying
to corrupt once again the election for
his own benefit the president has
engaged in abuse of power
undermining our national security and
jeopardizing the integrity of our
elections his actions are in defiance of
the vision of our founders and the oath
of office that he takes to preserve
protect and defend the Constitution of
the United States well the White House
response was Swift on Twitter President
Trump accused Democrats of having no
case saying I say if you're going to
impeach me do it now fast so we can have
a fair trial in the Senate and so that
our country can get back to business
well I want House correspondent Kimberly
healthcare is standing by with more
reaction from there but first let's go
to hi Joe Castro also in Washington DC
for Heidi first of all how significant
is Nancy Pelosi's announcement what is
she trying to achieve by okaying the
drafting of impeachment articles against
President Trump well it is a great
moment of political drama not only is
Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of the House of
Representatives but of course she's the
second in line to the presidency herself
so bringing the weight of the House
speaker's words to push this impeachment
forward saying that she is now asking
the Judiciary Committee to draft these
articles of impeachment it doesn't
change anything in the practical terms
of where we were already headed but it
brings more gravity to the situation and
it frames the significance of this
moment for the American
public so what is these articles of
impeachment what does that really mean
well these are the charges if you will
that the president would eventually face
if and as all signs indicate at this
point when this impeachment reaches the
Senate for the trial phase which would
determine whether or not Trump is
removed from office and so now the
pending question is what charges what
articles of impeachment will the
president be facing it appears that the
there is a push to narrowly focus these
articles on the abuse of power
allegations in Trump's dealing with
Ukraine there's also indication that
they may they may include obstruction of
Congress detailing the president's
efforts not to cooperate with the
impeachment inquiry itself and then
there's also the question of whether or
not Democrats will look back at the
Russia investigation the Moller report
which recommended several possible
obstruction of justice charges that
could be resolved in an impeachment as
well so what is next then in the process
its itself when can we expect the House
of Representatives to vote on these
articles of impeachment and then send
them to the Senate well since this
inquiry hit the ground Democrats have
been pushing forward at breakneck pace
and this only indicates that will be
sustained
right now we're hearing that a full vote
to impeach the president by the house
will be held around Christmas time which
would put us on track for the Senate
starting a trial in the new year in
January but how that trial will unfold
is very much an open question this has
only ever happened twice in the history
of US presidents where an impeachment
has reached the Senate phase and there's
still a lot at stake it's a lot to be
discussed among Democrats and
Republicans that will hash out what the
rules of that trial will be and of
course trying to make those rules
favorable to the arguments of either
side all right Kimberly Heidi rather
thank you very much for that we now go
to Kimberly Harket our White House
correspondent is going to tell us about
the reaction from the present
kimberley yeah a lot of activity here at
the White House follow we know that the
White House press staff had been huddled
up hours earlier as this announcement by
the House Speaker Nancy Pelosi was
taking place one of those officials
emerging just moments ago telling our
senior White House producer Chris
Sheridan that in fact there will be a
statement coming from the White House
later today we don't know if this will
be the president we don't know if this
will be the press secretary certainly
the press secretary has already reacted
she sent out a tweet saying that speaker
Pelosi and the Democrats should be
ashamed at real Donald Trump Hara the
president has done nothing but lead our
country resulting in a booming economy
more jobs a stronger military to name
just a few of his accomplishments we
look forward to a fair trial in the
Senate his campaign sending out a
similar statement we're looking forward
to a fair trial in the Senate
what are they saying the argument here
seems to be with the case that the
Republicans and the White House are
making to the American public is this
has been a partisan process in the House
of Representatives controlled by
Democrats you continually hear them
criticizing the process but not the
actual facts of the case it's very clear
that there is an attempt to try and
defend the president not on the merits
of the arguments of whether or not he
committed any wrongdoing but instead on
the process which Republicans argue has
been skewed for political purposes thank
you for that Kimberly Hoff ket live for
us at the White House